hablamos de economía aquí en directo
américa y me acompaña en el estudio del
señor luís méndez y dices bienvenido que
bueno tenerte de por acá en el estudio
directo américa vamos a empezar a hablar
de argentina porque ese país mantiene
las negociaciones con el fondo monetario
internacional para el pago de la deuda
así es raúl y de acuerdo con un artículo
que fue publicado por el diario
argentino ámbito financiero las
negociaciones llevadas a cabo en roma a
lo largo de este fin de semana podrían
haber abierto un nuevo panorama para
evitar que la nación caiga en default
esa ha sido la premisa en todo momento
el presidente alberto fernández desde
que asumió el poder no obstante también
ha mantenido la intención de que el
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional sea el más productivo para
argentina por el momento no hay nada
concreto pero entre las opciones es de
acuerdo con el referido diario podría
operar un pacto stand still que es un
acuerdo entre deudor y acreedor en la
que el deudor está obligado a no caer en
default al tiempo que los acreedores
están obligados a no emprender acciones
o requerir hasta finalizar el proceso de
negociación por el momento con esfuerzo
argentina ha cumplido con el pago de
intereses por el orden de 2 mil 470
millones de dólares ayer precisamente
efectúa un pago de
390 millones y en diciembre deberá
cancelar alrededor de 1880 millones de
dólares sólo en pago de intereses a
pesar de los avances el riesgo país
volvió a elevarse en la nación y en la
jornada de ayer se ubicó en
1728 puntos su mayor nivel desde
septiembre del año 2020 bueno louis si
seguimos en el sur de nuestro continente
americano porque el presidente de
brasilia el cuestionar anunció que desea
disminuir el precio del dice así lo
anunció un artículo de folha de sao
paulo
durante el viaje italia el presidente
manifestó que podría tomar los
dividendos que produjo la empresa
petrobras para invertirlos en la
reducción de los combustibles de acuerdo
con la nota la posición del presidente
es que los elevados precios del diesel
que han subido un 65 por ciento de las
refinerías
en los surtidores están impactando la
inflación adicionalmente los altos
precios del combustible han elevado el
descontento de los transportistas por lo
que se han promovido algunas huelgas en
estados como minas gerais río de janeiro
y para así es luís y todo listo para la
reunión de la reserva federal en eeuu y
sobre ella ha se ha generado muchas
expectativas ya que los principales
mercados mundiales esperan que el
organismo analice las medidas para
controlar la inflación y mantener la
recuperación económica dentro de eeuu al
mismo tiempo sin embargo de acuerdo con
una publicación de la agencia de
noticias ap se espera que del encuentro
se anuncie el inicio del recorte de 120
mil millones que han sido destinados a
lo largo de la compra mensual de bonos
estas compras están destinadas a
mantener bajas las tasas de préstamos
para fomentar el endeudamiento así mismo
el organismo debe analizar la manera en
que elevará la tasa de interés de
referencia para evitar que la inflación
se salga de control pero llevaría
consigo desalentar el gasto y socavar el
mercado laboral ante una recuperación
total de la economía y se ofrecieron los
datos del crecimiento del sector
manufacturero en la zona euro list así
es raúl y esto tiene que ver con los
datos del índice de gerentes de compras
que fueron revelados el día de hoy en
este sentido el pm y como se le conoce
por sus siglas en inglés reveló que el
sector manufacturero de la zona euro
cayó a un mínimo de ocho meses a
58,3 en octubre debido a las continuas
interrupciones causadas por la pandemia
y los cuellos de botella que han sido
generados en la cadena de suministros
recordemos que este índice cuando una
nación o en este caso la zona euro está
por debajo de 50 genera contracción al
tiempo que por encima de 50 estaría
generando un buen ambiente dentro de la
industria le dice cómo están los
indicadores económicos hoy tenemos ya el
cierre en el mercado asiático donde con
algunos problemas en los principales
indicadores sobre todo en japón y en
hong kong cerraron con números negativos
también esto debido a los problemas que
hubo en cuanto a algunos sectores por
otro lado en el mercado europeo hubo
cierres mixtos a lo largo de la
operación cayó la bolsa de londres
afectada por el descenso en algunas
mineras louis y comenzó este martes con
deuda en el próximo bloque económico no
se trae la cifra del día puerto pues
nosotros vamos directo a la con 26